s'il y a mille et une façons de faire
l'amour et je le crois
il n'en n'est une exceptionnelle et qui
n'est pas à dédaigner la chose que se
faire devant trente personnes
ça ne dure que 10 secondes et ça se fait
avec les yeux on s'est peut-être vu déjà
deux ou trois fois pas davantage à des
dîners chez des personnes et ce soir on
est placé l'un en face de l'autre
à table on se regarde on se sourit on
est des gens bien élevés et l'on
s'adresse la parole mais le sujet qu'on
a choisi les croisières à l'automne
n'est qu'un prétexte assurément puisque
si l'on se parle on ne secoue de guerre
or voilà qu'un autre dialogue mais muet
celui là s'engage tout à coup les
regards ont cessé leurs va-et-vient
normal on les dirait planté à jamais la
dans l'autre et l'on questionne lowe's
et son regard répond zee
alors on ose donne toi je me donne
mais vous savez que je suis une femme
honnête c'est bien pour ça que c'est
merveilleux on coeur que le quart ac
nous sommes d'accord ça n'a duré que dix
secondes les regards ont repris leurs
va-et-vient normale et l'entretien qui
c'était un instant dénouer sur nous et
vous n'êtes jamais allés jusqu'en
finlande